[Musique]
trois tournages avec un point commun le
château de brousse et l édifice est
aujourd'hui vide de nombreux meubles
mais pour une bonne raison
deux ans et demi de travaux vont être
lancés le château vient de se trouver un
repreneur
il était donc racheter suite à un appel
d'offre qu'on a lancé quatre qui a duré
pendant un peu plus d'un an
donc on a fait un appel à propositions
pour la reprise du château et donc qui
on a sélectionné donc une famille
française qui est amoureux de l'art qui
a déjà investi dans un autre lieu sur
paris on a une visite des architectes
qui prévu dernière là on travaille
beaucoup ici avec la drac avec le
conservateur et la bf
donc on a eu la chance de pouvoir
construire un vrai projet avec eux et
donc ils sont partis là je pense à
partir à la fin de l'année on va partir
sur des débuts de travaux initialement
fondée en 1815 avec un premier bâtiment
sur les terres de chasse de louis xiv
construit pour la duchesse de chârost il
est racheté en 1938 par charles de
beistegui c'est un château qui a une
particularité c'est très peu de gens
savent que depuis 1950 jusque dans les
années 70 dates de 17 chars
d'investiguer tout le café society
parisien venait faire la fête au château
de brousse c'est ça toujours été privée
jusqu'en l'an 2000 quand la famille
décès d'yves avant de château c'est jean
vigué milieu qui va racheter le château
derrière et qui pendant dix ans va en
faire une restauration et va décider de
lui de l'ouvrir en partie au public il y
a 6 ans des amoureux du château et
d'histoire se lance dans l'aventuré et
créé l'association patrimoine aventure
c'est nous qui avons entre guillemets
initie cette volonté de découvrir qui
était cet ce personnage charles
domestique est de faire découvrir l'
influence qui là encore aujourd'hui sur
l'architecturé le design est donc on a
créé une visite qui permet à chacun de
comprendre la folie de cet homme mais
surtout l' influence sur l'architecturé
le design
le château est classé monument
historique depuis 1993 à l'issue des
travaux des artistes seront accueillis à
demeure on devrait encore l'apercevoir
dans de nombreux longs métrages
le site accueille toujours des équipes
de tournage
[Musique]
m